so so it's like like the these patterns
aren't conducive for families because
it's not good for kids to not have both
parents in the home
yeah like that's you know what i'm
saying like it's not conducive to
building family this is just like the
trends we're seeing you know what i mean
can i can i ask you a question yeah
which would you rather
see
a guy who you're really really into once
every two weeks
or a guy you're only kind of into
twice a week
the first one the first one the first
one as well because my dating style is
very much i'm quite independent and i
work i work in film i work quite a
demanding job sometimes i can be on set
for 12 hours
i or longer i've worked in a job before
i was on for 16 hours yeah sweet sweet
over time
but um so it's mainly because you're
busy right a busy and also just in
general my both of my parents are quite
independent people my mom loves to sit
at home and read she's she's she's very
she's she's so neutral she's so she's so
calm my mom has such a calming presence
in my life my dad is like me and my dad
is batshit and i love it but my parents
they work so well together because no
one could date my dad like my mom and no
one could date my mom like my dad and
they balance each other out really well
and they are both very independent
people and they're very happy to do
their own thing they don't need to be in
each other's space all the time and i
really like that and that's something i
like now and the thing that i admire and
and i tend to date people who are busy
bodies and people who are ambitious and
things because that's the quality i have
and i also like people who who uh who
want to do other things and i'm not
their soul hobby no i'm not saying are
you cool with a boyfriend you see twice
a month
sure so
the reason the reason i ask that
question is because i think
it's exactly that reason
that
the date in landscape is the way it is
now because most girls would rather
see the guy they really want
less
than the guy who's ready to be there for
them more
i think which end which is how you end
up having one guy
having six seven eight nine girls
because they would all roll i don't know
why you're laughing
uh but rather
is this what's happening to you
absolutely but it's true but it's true
though like they'd rather see they'd
rather like they'd rather shoot they
didn't know do you know man they have it
i know
you know there's a couple but but
i would i would say who wants to see
someone that they kind of like of course
everybody wants to see the places
but what i'm trying to say is like
they're i think before they used to
prioritize
commitment
a bit not over quality but
more compared to quality but now it's
like we only care about quality and if
it means i only get five percent of him
then i'd rather take that but i don't
think the amount of time you spend with
someone equates commitment look at
long-term relationships you can still be
in a really commit relationship if it's
a long uh uh if it's long distance sorry
not long time if it's a long distance
relationship you don't think there's a
higher level of commitment if you're
like living with someone oh yeah like i
mean but i think it depends on what
framework if you've got bills if you've
got shared bills of course that is right
like that's that is a commitment because
you you both financially have to
supplies like if one of you loses a job
it's like
great
but i think i i i think that people want
different things i know a lot of women
and i know a lot of men who are much
more dependent people and they want to
be with their partner a lot and that's
fine those people tend to find each
other
i think it just depends what kind of
person you are and i think a lot of it
depends how you're raised as well like
if you're raised with parents who love
to be with each other all the time then
i think you learn by that behavior and
you go this is what a healthy
relationship looks like
and to me i think not being in each
other's space all the time is what i
prefer but for me i'm like okay if you
love being around each other that's
great i still love being around my
partners don't get me wrong it's just
that if i'm working a really long job if
i've got loads of other stuff and i've
got a lot of friends and i want to see
those guys too and i think that's okay i
think if you see someone if you're
living with them like of course i'm
going to see my partner more but i've
never i you know i've not lived with any
of my partners so i'm not having that
natural kind of being around them when i
come home thing in which case i would
see them more
so so coming off his question right say
if you're seeing a guy like every two
weeks at some point like obviously you
guys are sleeping together like every
two weeks what not after say like five
months
i feel like it's safe to say at some
point you'd want to see more
uh
if you are progressing in terms of oh
okay now we're gonna buy a house
together or we're gonna move in together
then oh no no no if you want to take
them seriously just yeah like a serious
relationship because i i feel like
when i gotta go sleeping together at
some point
the girl is going to be like cool like
two weeks is a bit of a long time like
and i'd like to know that a lot so once
you narrate a lot and you tell him
you're like look i'm trying to see more
often and he's like
i kind of like it the way it is
think i think it depends i think it
depends what as well what his reasons is
if it's like sorry i can only see you
two weeks because i'm away for work or
i'm doing this or whatever you go okay
fair enough and also again this is we're
talking within a heteronormative and
monogamous relationship we're not
accounting for anything like polyamory
but if you of you if you're dating
someone monogamously
yeah sometimes people have career
let me ask the guys um
you guys had a girlfriend
yeah ever ever yeah ever would they have
been cool with seeing you twice a month
no chance
no chance no i actually um one of my
relationships my longest term
relationship ended because of long
distance
and just not seeing each other as
frequently
um
yeah distance is the worst i don't think
long-distance relationships work oh my
god i yeah i tried that it crashed and
burned
i've tried that too i don't think unless
you have plans in place to make it not
long distance i don't think it's
sustainable what do you consider
distance like an hour two hours three
i'd say
enough distance where if you couldn't
if they had a really bad day and you
couldn't see them that evening
because they're too far it's too far
it's gonna be like two hours
i'd say five to be honest
you don't think that's what you do you
meet someone to have a bad day for like
four hours well if they were like five
hours away
if they're four hours away
if you like
but my my long distance she was in
australia like oh yeah oh oh so anything
closer than that i think i could
probably do america uk somewhere
because you've got the time difference i
mean same with you as well you've got a
time difference and yeah yeah
there's only so many hours like a window
where you can really like chat to each
other yeah yeah yeah yeah so
if you missed that
i'm gonna read super chats really quick
um thank you guys for the super chats
just you guys know
all super chats um
i i i don't even pay myself at this
point it's just being reinvested into
the studio we're doing a studio revamp
in the next week it's going to be really
cool we're getting more mics we're
getting more equipment
thankful for all of you guys because you
guys are the ones that really make this
happen also like the video there's 105
of you in here
like that's dope okay
um let's start with the super chats um
five dollars from blue pill unplugged um
a 304 is a bad bet for paternity a guy
can't be sure who his kid is hard line
in the sand next one 8.99 from samuel
udo saying you'd rather sleep around and
have more soul ties as well to me
um
i am just jewels five dollars love
seeing the improvements keep it up okay
thank you guys
um
also guys if you send any more i'll read
them like pretty quick
so next question